a catastrophe or a violent shock whether
natural or man-made creates an
exceptional state of emergency in any
society where it enables change
but also paves the way to opportunism
the united states were searching for a
pretext to go to war with iraq saddam
was saying it's a danger to the world
the events of 9 11 were used to re-wire
the world system countries allied with
the us carried out the intentional mass
murder of civilians this is what can
happen to you if you rise up you really
better get in line
has crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't think the united states
priorities were really taking care of
iraqi people this mass slaughter was
considered a success and an inspiration
for other authoritarian movements around
the world you had the genocide of actual
killing the bodies but also the killing
of the mental framework of how you look
at the world
hyperinflation wars
and massacres
are certainly disruptive shocks to any
country
but are they orchestrated by more
powerful countries and governments in
order to parasite on the opportunity
when my father passed away it left a
huge hole in my life
it was devastating
you never see it coming
it takes a while to find your new place
after such a massive disruption to life
as you know it
i learned a lot from my dad
i learned to be committed
and to pursue what's right
and to search for the truth
and to ask questions
those years
there were many
changes
and many more would come
[Music]
my father got to see 911
but when iraq was occupied
he had already passed away
maybe it's better he didn't see all
these conflicts wars and destruction
that flooded all over the arab world
afghanistan iraq
and later syria
yemen libya
[Applause]
conflicts leave deep marks in the people
who fight them and in those around them
[Music]
the oscar-nominated filmmaker james
longley knows that very well
his documentary iraq and fragments shows
how the iraqi people lived during the
first two years of the iraq war
when i got back to iraq in
april 2003 the place was pretty much a
shambles
people were
living in fear that shops would close up
in the early afternoon there was a lot
of crime because the united states had
overthrown the government and what do
you expect to happen
of course in the absence of the
government and of the the police and so
on crime was rampant and ordinary life
was
suddenly impossible
so i think the thing americans fail to
grasp about
wars like this is that when you
overthrow government even if the
government is disliked
it's still maybe the thing
[Music]
keeping
everything together and when the
government goes away
uh all bets are off
saddam hussein is not disarming
he is a danger to the world
he must disarm
the liberation of iraq is a crucial
advance in the campaign against terror
we've removed an ally of al qaeda
no terrorist network will gain weapons
of mass destruction from the iraqi
regime
because the regime
is no more
[Music]
you could see that the united states
that the bush administration they were
searching for a pretext to go to war
with iraq
i don't think the united states
priorities were really
taking care of iraqi people
you can see in the way that the united
states invaded uh iraq and overthrew the
government without any
real planning about what was going to
happen next uh i think that act by
by
itself uh
shows you the mentality of the people
who are making the decisions and their
absence of interest really in
the well-being of iraqi people
there have been wars as long as there
have been humans on earth
but would anybody cause war or economic
disruption on purpose to achieve some
other goal than winning the war
what about disasters that are not caused
by humans
natural disasters for instance
nobody provokes those
nobody makes a hurricane happen or an
earthquake
but are these disasters also taken as an
opportunity
american writer vincent devins author of
the jakarta method may offer a response
to my questions
can you please explain to me what is
exactly the jakarta method the jakarta
method is a book about the intentional
murder
of civilians for being left-wing or for
being accused
of wing and and the reason it has this
name the jakarta method
is because the most important event in
this story and though not the first one
is in 1965 when the u.s backed
indonesian military intentionally killed
approximately one million innocent
civilians for being leftist or being
associated somehow with opponents to the
new right-wing regime backed by the
united states
this horrible mass slaughter
was considered
a success and an inspiration for other
right-wing or authoritarian movements
around the world and they thought oh
we can do that like they did it will
work for us and also the united states
will back us in doing so and in also
washing our reputations afterwards
what are these other places you
mentioned where people were subject to
extreme brutality to pursue a certain
economic or political agenda i found
that in at least 20 countries around the
world
countries allied with the us
carried out the intentional mass murder
of this are people they called leftists
so that they could create
authoritarian capitalist regimes
allied with the united states
they used the word jakarta to denote
what they were going to do to their own
left wing so in chile in 1972 there was
a terror campaign that consisted of
graffiti on the walls of the city that
said jakarta is coming and what that
meant is we're going to kill our
left-wing movements just like the
indonesians killed their leftists and
that is
ultimately exactly what happened in 1973
when the u.s
backed coup that removed salvador
allende and installed pinochet
the head of pinochet's secret service
bragged that he was able to
crush rebellion with only 3 000 deaths
because the point of those deaths was
not only to eliminate these people that
they believed to be a threat the point
of these deaths was to make the rest of
the country understand
we're in power
this is what can happen to you if you
rise up
you really better get in line
the suharto dictatorship did not kill a
third of the country right that would
have been
unnecessary from the very cruel logic of
the jakarta method what they did is they
took people away from their families
arrested them
and then killed them
in such a way that nobody in the in the
country knew what had happened to them
this is called disappearances
when you have a family member or
friend that is
in a situation that you don't understand
i know they went to jail but i don't
know if they're dead or not
that stops populations from rising up
because they believe well if i rise up
that might be the thing that gets my son
killed
what about natural disasters
um what i will say about natural
disasters acts of god hurricanes
earthquakes and things like this
is that in general they're bad for the
global economy they're bad for growth
worldwide but there are particular
actors that always find a way to make a
profit off of
emergency loans emergency uh
services
so while i would question the idea that
the global elite as a whole do well off
of natural disasters i will say that the
global financial system is
fine-tuned enough and active in enough
parts of the world
that somebody is probably going to make
money when there is a huge need for
rebuilding
i know what you're thinking about
when things are so clear and organized
there's not much room for doubt
and any further questions could be
useless
[Music]
in mid-2018 the united nations refugee
agency recognized 8.7 million refugees
originating from the arab region
this is one of the consequences to the
events that recently shook the arab
countries
but could these shocks respond to one
specific interest
what happened to the arab world after 9
11.
how did the west exploit what happened
i am asking this question to hate him
besien professor of theology at zaituna
college
the first muslim accredited liberal arts
college in the united states
i wanted to talk to you about the
violent interventions in the arab or
muslim world orchestrated by the west
whether you want to call it the shock
doctrine or the jakarta method or
plain old imperialism and colonialism
the shock doctrine is to use any natural
event
any uh
major event any uh war
uh to re-configure the society
so the events of 9 11
were used
as a way
to
re-wire
the world system
into a singular focus
on the muslim subject
in particular the united states
used the opportunity to extend their
footprint
having bases and military operations
almost 74 countries
the 911 brought also regime change to a
security state
that is emerging from a post-colonial
structure
is it all for political and economic
gains or
is there something else 911 was also a
process of uh
using
regime change
uh in the region
and regime changing here involved
bringing islam into circulation
upon demonization of the muslim subject
there is the good muslim and the bad
muslim so if you're a good muslim you're
a person who accept to be dominated
colonized and the bad islam is anyone
that says what's happening to our
country what's happening to our
resources so you had the genocide of
actual killing the bodies but also the
killing of the mental framework of how
you look at the world
when my father died
we were in shock and disoriented
[Music]
we had to find our bearings
[Music]
i believe nations are like families
any individual feels the same joy or
sadness or shock as his family
and they can at that moment be
vulnerable to abuse
and it helps to know the difference
between opinion and principle
i see the difference in opinion
as something essential and healthy
but the difference in principle
that's another story which requires
different questions
[Music]
you